to most of the world
this is Esports 10 seconds
no time he just has to watch that club
take down
I'm taking the major it's played on PC
with mouse and keyboard or on console
with controller and Gamepad but for an
entirely different part of the world
this is
these vampire Esports might have their
run cut down here but they have done
enough only Ravens will left hits the
deck for a drop shot and that is the end
of their story but it is now back to
back and Seoul going head-to-head the
team from India four players alive with
a heavy elimination game buying the
final but we are gonna go over to the
stage for the trophy ceremony mobile
Esports have exploded over the past few
years in large part thanks to one
company Qualcomm but who is Qualcomm and
what do they have to do with us going
from playing brick breaker on our
blackberries to competing online with
our phones
[Applause]
blasting through the Grand finals and
Engraving their names into the cosmos as
your first ever icon
[Applause]
okay so before we get started I just
want to say a huge thank you to Qualcomm
Technologies and the entire Snapdragon
Elite Gaming Team for making this
episode possible mobile Esports are on
the come up and we are super excited to
be sharing this new scene with you all
today's video is brought to you by the
Snapdragon Elite Gaming Team for
champion level gameplay that's sure to
leave you feeling triumphant make sure
you check out the brand new Samsung
Galaxy s23 Ultra powered by the fastest
Snapdragon ever and available right now
okay back to the video so more people
game on their phones than any other
platform in the world some of your
favorite games may have been downloaded
millions of times on PC and console but
mobile is actually just on an entirely
different level we're talking billions
of installs of games that are a lot like
what you're already playing on PC hell
nowadays you can play full-blown battle
royales and mobas on your phone I know
some of you are probably a little too
young to remember playing games on your
parents Blackberry but I sure do so how
did we get here well there were a few
major advancements that really allowed
developers to push the limits on what
games on mobile could be and Qualcomm
has been a big part of those changes
there are Semiconductor Company based in
San Diego who for years wanted to
improve graphics and make these games
look as realistic as possible and
despite being known for mobile
technology Qualcomm has actually been
around in Esports for quite some time if
you're a long time LCS viewer you
probably remember that TSM used to be
called TSM Snapdragon as in Qualcomm
Snapdragon these guys are ogs but to
really make an impact in Esports
they had another problem to solve first
you see Esports have always been
primarily played on PC and console and
Qualcomm were primarily focused on
making mobile games look better and
better which makes sense because for
many casual players Graphics are King a
lot of modern AAA titles at 4K are
absolutely breathtaking but when it
comes to Esports refresh rates are
actually a lot more important it's
crucial to maintain High FPS when
players compete at the biggest events in
the world Qualcomm also wanted to solve
problems that PC Esports players faced
for folks playing on their own mobile
platform but there were still tons of
other problems for them to overcome like
power supply you see modern graphics
cards consume quite a lot of power how
much power do you ask
well I don't know but that does sound
like something that my good friend
Colton would know right Colton
right and now the guy who actually knows
what he's talking about hey everybody
your friendly neighborhood guy who used
to sell phones back again they don't
call me the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about for nothing yes
desktop and even laptop graphics cards
tend to draw a lot of power but let's
face it lately Nvidia has turned that
dial up to 11. an RTX 4090 for example
can draw roughly 450 Watts so Nvidia
recommends an 850 watt power supply but
today we aren't actually talking about
computers so how much power can your
phones comparatively tiny battery pump
out well it's roughly three and a half
Watts yup three and a half and it's
actually been that way for ages now ever
since the release of the first iPhone
back in 2007 really you're gonna make me
use an iPhone reference who wrote this
smartphones have all basically delivered
the same amount of power give or take a
couple of watts and because of this
30fps games have stayed made the norm
while PC and even console gaming has
surged ahead so Qualcomm wanted to
change that but even if they got games
to run at 60fps on 60hz displays that's
an incredibly narrow tightrope to walk
they wanted to improve displays and gpus
without drawing obscene amounts of power
so over the past decade our Mobile gpus
on Snapdragon have increased by orders
of magnitude think about it we've gone
from Mega flops to teraflops that's a 10
000 X increase in performance and what
that means is we can now run all the
latest like desktop features like
Hardware accelerated or a chac where you
can basically do tens of billions of Ray
intersects per second all within an
average of a 3.5 watt power available
and we include uh like the latest game
engines like Unreal Engine 5 now and
that's all running on a device that fits
in your pocket pretty amazing and
finally in 2018 Qualcomm Snapdragon was
the first chip set to support a 90 Hertz
display for years you know even on
desktop you were always maxed out and
even in console you're always maxed out
at like 60 FPS and that had to do with
the display refresh rate how fast could
it update the display even though the
GPU could render at a higher frame rate
and so what we've seen in the last five
years is breaking that whole barrier
that boundary which completely
revolutionized the next generation of
mobile gaming but Qualcomm didn't stop
at 90. these days some smartphones
support 120 and even 144 Hertz displays
OLED panels have also allowed games to
run much more smoothly on mobile devices
thanks to their ultra low response time
and that's a technology we're just
starting to see in high-end gaming
monitors pair all this with massive
improvements to mobile game engines like
unreal in terms of both performance and
availability and gaming on your phone is
starting to look pretty fully featured
and it's not even just Esports titles
major franchises are being developed
from the ground up for mobile the rise
of mobile gaming has been pretty
Monumental around the world we went from
playing games on Tiny low-res displays
with Blackberry scroll wheels two 4K FPS
games on touchscreens what a time to be
alive and that was the guy who actually
knows what he's talking about thanks
Colton but getting mobile games to run
on 90 FPS wasn't the only big thing to
happen back in 2018
I can't believe I'm saying this but uh
let's talk about fortnite as 4G networks
became more accessible battle royale's
like fortnite and pubg dominated the
mobile gaming space in 2018. players
could now compete with each other online
on their phones with extremely low
Network latency even if they weren't at
home and thanks to all these changes
Mobile gaming and Esports have grown
astronomically in some parts of the
world where phones are beating PC and
consoles as the most popular gaming
platform titles like pubg Call of Duty
wild Rift and plenty more are absolutely
taking over a huge reason for this is
accessibility not everyone has access to
a fancy gaming PC but pretty much
everyone has a smartphone the average
person probably only has a normal 60hz
1080p Monitor and chances are that their
phone display is better in nearly every
way it likely has a higher pixel density
higher resolution higher refresh rate
and better response time you don't have
to make nearly as many sack sacrifices
to play games on your phone these days
you can run them at high frame rates
with features like Ray tracing without
losing performance and all this allowed
mobile Esports to blow up over the last
few years and in partnership with ESL
Qualcomm is working to make it even
bigger what if the thrill of Competitive
Gaming and the excitement of elite
competition were accessible at any time
from any player's pocket anywhere around
the globe
introducing the Snapdragon Pro Series
the world's Premier Global multi-genre
Mobile Esports competition the
Snapdragon Pro Series is now the world's
largest mobile Esports platform we want
to make mobile Esports accessible to
everyone all over the world and so we
have people at all skill levels now that
can play Esports on mobile and we're
seeing all kinds of people play and all
these different regions and globally in
these tournaments so we wanted to make
it more accessible for mobile Esports
competition and and Community I think
they've done it
as well the Turkish scene rise for your
Champions parlor they've done it
absolutely incredible stuff the
snapdragger Pro Series Finals winner
live in Valencia will be Paula a
magnificent performance for the Turkish
team who have turned up and dominated
their way through this final mobile
Esports have grown tremendously thanks
to huge leaps forward in the hardware
that powers them today we've shipped
over 3.5 billion Mobile gpus in our in a
market that are available on smartphones
today I think a lot of people don't
realize how much we do on gpus or how
many gpus we've shipped right so we've
shipped more mobile gpus than even on
desktop which is a pretty amazing
statistic when you think about it most
Esports Pros are using massive PCS that
hold all their components and keep them
cool so the fact that Qualcomm has found
ways to run full-blown Esports titles on
smartphone owns is remarkable a lot of
our technology we've actually gotten a
lot of requirements and feedback from
Pro Esports players how do you make the
device better how do I get more faster
response times and how do I get
completely rid of motion blur and so a
lot of the technologies that we built
and customize have been in mind for that
Pro Esports player we really then
invested a lot in helping grow these
mobile Esports Leagues with a lot of our
partners and bringing more people to
mobile and now that you've seen that
transition where more people are playing
on mobile Esports than any other
platform if you're like us and you've
been living and breathing Esports for
years
mobile Esports may not be the first
scene that Springs to mind but for
decades Gamers have competed on whatever
platform is available to them it's why
fighting game communities sprung up
around arcades or later home consoles
it's why kids flocked to PC bombs in
Korea and now for millions of people
around the world the most accessible
gaming device
fits straight in their pocket that's
gonna change things it already has we
don't know what the future will bring
but right now for mobile Esports
it looks bright
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and tick tock